this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
all right everybody I am back with
Jonathan pajel on his own channel
interviewing him about a very important
event coming up that you're going to
want to know all about was that a good
intro Jonathan that was perfect great
okay here we go so what are we talking
about today and so we are talking about
the symbolic World Summit we you know
this is something that has been kind of
floating around for a long time we might
have done it already if it wasn't for
kovid but now we we're going to do it
and so Neil he came back to me and he
was we have to we have to get together
in person we have to you keep saying
that we have to meet in person with
people and not just meet online and so
let's do this yeah I totally agree well
every time we've gotten together in
person this is something that's come up
and we've talked about because it's got
to be one of the most requested things
around the symbolic world is an actual
in-person conference it's long overdue
so we're looking at here I'm looking at
the dates we're looking at 2024
February 29th through the 2nd in Tarpon
Springs Florida now if you're not
familiar with Tarpon Springs let's talk
about that a little bit have you ever
been Jonathan no I've never been to
Target at one point it was the sponge
capital of the world which is one of his
strange claims to fame well but when it
comes to sponge diving and the Greek
technique of sponge diving it became
such a popular spot that uh it is now
the
um I guess it's the largest Greek
population per capita in the United
States so there's a number of Orthodox
Church there and great people there and
there's a wonderful church called Saint
Nicholas
um they had a weeping icon of Saint
Nicholas in the 1970s you can actually
see that if you come and uh the town has
got some of the best Greek food and it's
got a wonderful Conference Center so it
uh it felt like the ideal location when
we were talking with the promoters
because it's so close to all the parks
in Orlando it's close to beaches in
Clearwater it's close to Tampa there's
lots of airports lots of places to stay
easy to get in some of the most
incredible eating in Florida which is
saying saying a lot so I think it's you
know it just makes perfect sense because
who doesn't want to come to Florida uh
late February early March yeah
especially if you're from Canada and so
and so we we bounce it around and we
have a theme it's called restoring the
cosmic image
basically we are we feel like we're at
this point of reenchantment you know we
feel like things are kind of moving in
that direction and it's becoming
possible again to recapture a more
embodied and more connected vision and
participation in the world so we're
gonna try to explore that together all
the all the the people that are coming
we have some amazing speakers you want
to announce some of the speakers Neil oh
I do uh well you can tell us about them
so we have uh first off we're gonna go
with Martin Shaw now for those people
who don't know Martin Shaw you're going
to love him so if you've been following
the channel and you haven't seen Martin
on the channel or speaking with Jonathan
uh Jonathan like what is his what is his
real like title like he's an actual
mythographer which means that he he's a
Stanford professor of Mythology but he's
also someone who like lives in the woods
for months at a time and
and uh and does all these crazy things
he's that he's an amazing Storyteller
his stories are wonderful he's he really
is that ancient kind of Storyteller he
he used to do a version of the of the
Odyssey in nine days where he would tell
the story for like nine days straight
and he was able to keep people's
attention he said half of the people
would go crazy and then the other half
would just be completely like locked in
uh and so he's an amazing Storyteller
we've already did some we did some
events in in England and in Ireland
together and we have a a really great
Rapport and we have a lot of Sparks that
fly when we when we exchange we discuss
her he's gonna he's gonna talk and then
the big well he's well you know just
interrupt you cutting in no uh I when
I've heard him talk like the way he
illuminates things and like how excited
I get as an artist and someone who
thinks like this it's it's almost like
he's impossible it's like I didn't know
there was a person like him or a person
could be that committed to this and that
engaging on the subject so I that when
you when you mentioned him I thought
that was like the most perfect fit
and so the second speaker uh is the one
that a lot of people from the Sabbath
world are going to be excited about we
have father Stephen DeYoung who's going
to come speak to us and that is going to
be that it's going to be amazing so I'm
really excited to have him be there
exchanging with all the symbolic world
people exchanging with me exchanging
with Neil you know have you met father
Stephen not yet no uh uh tease him
online that's about it it's incredible I
mean the Lord of spirits podcast is just
got to be one of my favorite podcasts
period uh the stuff father Stephen knows
and the way he articulates it I feel
like what I learned from him sometimes
is like stuff I thought I was going to
have to wait you know to get to Paradise
to ask God about and like Father Stephen
can illuminate some of these things so I
mean that's quite a setup I'm sure but
uh I mean I don't think anyone's going
to be disappointed to meet him or even
ask them their own strange questions
about Giants in person in person so
Martin Sean father Stephen they're going
to be the headlining speakers with
myself and then we're going to have all
these different paths for different
types of people and uh so there'll be
like main events with everybody together
and then we'll also have pass for
artists that will be headed up uh by our
friend Neil right here
yeah I'm excited to do that I've invited
Vesper Stamper if you guys are familiar
with Vesper uh she's uh I guess you
could call her a Renaissance woman uh
she's quite a racketeer herself as as
far as storytelling um she's a visual
artist she was been she's been a
musician and she's a well-published
author
um and so we're gonna tag team that
event and hopefully help artists answer
some of the toughest questions they've
been asking which is how do I integrate
the symbolic thinking and symbolism into
my storytelling how do I integrate it
into my artwork uh we're gonna I'm gonna
answer questions like that and we're
gonna go on even to more practical stuff
about publishing your work finishing
your work getting it out there all right
so then we have another path which is
going to be the universal history path
with everybody knows who's going to be
doing that it'll be Richard Roland and
he will have someone too but we don't
know he might have someone helping him
out but we're not sure who yet
and then we have a third path which is
going to be what is the third path
called it's like you guys had mentioned
it is it's about grounding symbolism in
The home and in your life something to
do with the Hearth like yeah so like how
to integrate symbolism into your actual
life well there's another thing going on
the very first night we get there that
is the biggest that is the biggest thing
that's gonna happen that has me the most
excited so what is it well uh you know
so we are getting back on the road Dirk
Paul Robbins and we're gonna do our
release show uh on February 29th the
very first night leap year leap year
we're gonna take the leap and we're
gonna do a concert at the symbolic World
um releasing our new completed record
firebird and so that's amazing so we
have the chance to see Drupal Robbins in
concert first time ever like my kids
they told me they want to come now to
this event just because of that they
didn't want to come before but when they
found out that durable Robbins is
playing at the symbolic World Summit
they're like Dad we got to go to Florida
so so that is really exciting so you got
to be there in person to see it there's
no other way to see it uh we're not
doing a ton of touring next year so
we've got a couple of shows leading up
to that one and a few shows afterwards
but that's probably going to be our one
of our bigger events of the Year all
right so we're looking at you know
around 500 people there's maybe a little
possibility for a few more we've got VIP
tickets and then we've got regular
tickets uh people if you want some of
those VIP tickets you definitely have to
come in early because those are going to
go really fast and it's going to be a
great time also just to meet people from
the symbolic World be people in person
uh people that are have been on my
Channel people that have had me on their
channels it's going to be I think it's
going to be great to actually to just be
there with and have sit around a table
and talk to people right now is there
going to be like a social channel on the
website because I know you have some
pretty cool social features uh for
people to interact in your website which
I which I would recommend leading into
the concert a concert conference and
concert and concert as well yeah so
people can sign up to the
symbolicworld.com we have a community
there that is thriving we have amazing
things going on already discussions
about novels so on the community right
now we're already having the Beowulf
course we also have a course on CS Lewis
and the space Trilogy by Andy Crawford
there's going to be a course on
metaphysics coming with JP Marceau so
it's really the place to already rev up
your relationships get to know people
get a sense of who's coming so that so
that once we arrive already we're ready
to discuss and ready to exchange and to
and to get to know each other perfect
I'm looking forward to seeing everybody
too I've been interacting with in person
uh so many people so the event details
again are February 29th through March
2nd this is 2024 it's in Tarpon Springs
Florida to are on sale now you can find
a link in the description of this video
I don't know what else to say Tarpon is
a wonderful area again like I'm gonna
put a map up right now look at how close
you are to everything else you want to
do in Florida while you're here so just
make it a trip come down and hang out
with us it's going to be incredible all
right see you there